what do you mean you aren't training
your suboccipital so neck training let's
get into it why would you want to train
your neck there's actually been
something of a neck Renaissance lately
with more more people suddenly
interested in training their neck and
there's two big reasons that a lot of
people give for this the first is
obviously a stetic a lot of people like
the way that a big neck looks if you
have a really big bulky body muscular
but you have a scrawly thin neck it
looks really odd and if somebody works
out through a body builder then often
your neck is one of the only things that
people see if you want to avoid the Ned
Flanders effect then you want a big
thick neck so that people know you work
out your neck is actually a site of much
higher androgen receptor density the
same goes to the traps that means if you
have high levels of testosterone you
have a thicker neck and bigger traps
this in turn gives off a kind of alpha
vibe so if you want to look mean and in
charge then a thick neck is a good way
to go the other big reason that people
tend to give is so that they can avoid
concussions they're bigger and stronger
your neck the greater you'll be at
absorbing impacts straight to your head
while this is all good and well it's not
the reason that I'm interested in
training your neck you see your neck
actually has a ton of other useful
benefits that make it really important
for general performance after all your
neck houses the conduit between your
brain and the rest of your nervous
system that makes it really important
and that's why damage to the neck is so
serious it's also why training in there
coz actually been shown to improve the
transmission of these signals thereby
potentially improving things like the
prior section possibly even mental
performance
similarly training a neck can actually
potentially improve your vo2 max if you
train the scalene muscles these actually
work a little bit like a pump when they
contract and relax thereby acting as a
kind of pump creating pressure
differentials to support the function of
the lungs but beyond this your neck is
crucially important for stabilizing your
head and keeping it steady when you're
running when you're fighting when you're
jumping you have lots of little muscles
in your neck and these all work to
support your head keeping your gaze
steady and counteracting the movement of
your body when you're running for
instance which is obviously going to
affect your speed and performance
likewise if you start falling your neck
is extremely important for balance it
helps to keep your center of gravity
correct and actually there's a higher
density of muscle spindles in your neck
as well the muscles are highly
proprioceptive meaning they're giving
lots of feedback to the nervous system
helping you to balance the neck is also
what we use to intentionally rotate and
move our skulls whether were dodging a
punch or we're tracking an object with
our gaze that's things like rate of
force development to actually really
important for the neck and if you want
to track something your eyes normally
move first followed by your neck your
neck instigates the movement for the
rest of your body or as well known neck
training advocate Mike gitelson notes
where your gaze goes your body follows
in other words need to look at something
before you can run towards it and your
neck plays a huge role in this all this
comes under the topic of eye head
coupling in fact to demonstrate this try
standing completely still and looking
forward then place one hand on the back
of your head and try moving your eyes
and you'll feel the tiny muscles in your
neck moving this is happening in order
to prepare your neck for movement to
follow your gaze
that's the splenius capitis by the way
and finally of course we use our necks
of things like back handspring tiny to
baylor whip it backwards for backflips
we tuck our neck into our body even for
jumping level throw our head up in the
air so again rate of force development
important the neck is the
of your corner if you're training your
abs and your erector spinae then you
need to be training your neck as well
and in fact failure to do so can cause
problems and imbalances as we'll see in
a moment so that's why you should be
training your neck the next question is
how do you go about doing it
conventional wisdom says that working
your traps and your laps of things like
deadlifts and shrugs is going to be
enough to strengthen your neck however
as Geoff nipper had explained in his
excellent video on this topic studies
actually show that training your neck
directly is far superior for increasing
neck mass and therefore probably neck
strength well the main advice you'll
hear is to use plate curls so you place
a plate on your head or your face and
then you curl your neck in order to move
the weight plate with just your neck you
normally use your hands to study the
weight and you can put a thin towel
between the plate and your face if it is
uncomfortable you're going to be lying
on a bench so your head is just over the
edge and then you're going to move just
the neck and I say the hands are only
there to steady the weight and make sure
it doesn't fall you'd only use to
heavier weight here five to ten pounds
is more than enough
if it goes well then you can do this
about three times a week you read around
the web and watch a lot of videos then
you'll hear about three common exercises
to do this with one is the neck flexion
where you're simply moving the head
forwards tilting the chin towards the
chest one is neck extension where you're
tilting backwards to look up at the
ceiling and then you have lateral
flexion which is tilting your head to
either side
you can also use a head harness and this
allows you to actually dangle away from
your head or attach it to a cable pulley
I bought one especially for this video
they do make it a little bit more
convenient to Train however they're also
ridiculous looking and you'll feel like
a complete lemon in your gym you look a
bit like [ __ ] of some sort so my actual
preference is to use isometric training
and self resistance in other words I
like to take my hand place it on my head
in the correct place and then push
against my head in order to work the
necessary muscles and you do this in all
the same directions and all the same
planes of movement and you can train
your neck that way this is an overcoming
isometric normally you'd use 100% force
I don't recommend you do that to begin
with because you could get strained and
neck rather aim for about 80% you should
hold each one of these for about six
seconds and I recommend doing about
three repetitions however studies show
that isometric training like this will
only train roughly thirty degrees of
movement meaning that you need to train
at least three points along each plane
so that way you'll cover the entire
range of motion so you're gonna do three
different positions for three reps
that's a total of nine reps for each
movement and you're doing three
movements and it shouldn't take too long
can easily do this at the end of a
workout or you could just do it whilst
you're watching TV it's really
convenient but those are not the only
reasons that I prefer doing isometric
one it keeps the resistance constant
you'll find this is a big problem when
you're doing plate curls when you're
using head harness because as your neck
changes angle of course the weight is
changing angle as well however when you
use your own hand you can make sure it
stays nice and constant and the other
reason I like it is it allows us to
actually train more planes of motion
it's actually there are three more ways
you can move your neck and three more
ways to Train it used to have neck
rotation which of course is turning your
head left to right which is really
important for tracking things it's also
really important for preventing that
concussive damage imagine you're taking
a hook to the side of the face it's
going to be your rotation that make sure
you don't completely whip your head back
likewise you have protraction which
means pushing your head forwards
shutting your chin and forehead outwards
and then you have a retraction where
you're moving your head backwards as
though you're trying to shrink it back
into your neck and give yourself no
Chin's a lot of people leave out this
training even though it's actually some
of the most important types of neck
training the reason being that you need
advanced equipment to be able to do it
of course you don't if you're just using
your own
so I highly recommend isometric training
for this now one of the big and most
contentious exercises for training your
neck is of course the neck bridge and
I've gone into more detail on this on my
website
generally the bottom line you can follow
the link in the description down below
but generally the bottom line is don't
do it because the risk to reward ratio
just isn't worth it most people don't
need it and as Jeff Cavaliere explains
in his video his excellent video on this
topic it can actually create neck spurs
over time because it's a closed chain
movements oh it's not about doing it
incorrectly it's not about not being
strong enough it's just simply about
your body adapting to this kind of
pressure and thereby making an
impingement more likely but if you want
to go even further beyond them what is
worth it is training the proprioceptive
the neck training the balance of the
neck and helping us to do all that stuff
I was talking about the beginning
keeping our head steady when running and
jumping helping us to balance better etc
and some great techniques for doing this
come from
ballerina science one of the issues that
we have to address is the fact that a
lot of us have imbalances in our neck
musculature and this is even more
prevalent today because so many of us
spend ages sitting at a computer or
texting on our phones with our heads
pointing down for instance many of us
will have overcompensation in our
sternocleidomastoid muscles and weaker
transverse abdominis and this can end up
causing you to have a jutting out chin
at all times of course making balance
much more difficult of course making you
look far less agile and graceful and of
course making you an easy target for a
left hook likewise many people carry
tension and tightness in their neck all
day long so we need to address this so
how do we do that well in the first
instance of course we would need to
train and strengthen our transverse
abdominis and you've seen plenty of tips
from me on how to do that with things
like the hollow body even plank front
levers in other words think of your neck
as part of your core and make sure it's
evenly developed at the same time you
should also be stretching and relaxing
and loosening those neck muscles as well
as strengthening them looking from side
to side and up and down and then rolling
your head around on the spot likewise
the static stretches you can just gently
push slightly beyond the comfortable
range of motion of course not hurting
yourself being very gentle and careful
we do this at the end of a workout and
likewise you need to maintain proper
posture throughout the day and be more
aware of that posture
I shared a cool video a while back
on how our knee improves his posture by
standing up against the wall but I
recently learned an even cooler tip from
ballerina badass which will tell you how
to hold your neck like a ballerina
basically you pretend that your head is
being pulled up by your ears
so you slightly straighten your neck
like that and that'll bring the chin in
then you slightly bring your chin up and
the tip she gives us to imagine that
you're completely disdainful of whoever
you're looking at and as soon as you
think like that your neck nicely
straightens out and when you do this it
allows you to bring in your transverse
abdominal
up your hip rotators and all of this
makes you lighter she explains it like
being a puppet but kind of lifted up by
your neck and head this allows you to
move much more freely and lightly with
the rest of your body you'll be far more
stable your balance will improve just by
practicing this one thing and it all
starts with the neck and then you can
practice listening to those muscle
spindles by trying to keep your head
nice and level by trying to keep it
perfectly still looking forwards whilst
you're engaging in a range of different
movements and that will help your
balance with time even though it might
be a little bit more difficult to begin
with for example if you're doing a
pistol squat or something this is the
perfect kind of movement to really be
aware of your neck to keep it nice and
steady
and to move slowly through that range of
motion it also recommends training with
faster movements I've talked in the past
about how valuable things like
cartwheels can be as part of your warm
up as well as tracking objects sports in
general are fantastic and things like
flips hand Springs etc a kip-up involves
the neck to a large degree as you can
see their neck training is about much
more than just plate curls the cervical
spine is the crucial endpoint of core
stability and is the prime instigator of
movement imbalance greater strength in
this area will improve your posture your
ability your balance your resilience and
your ability to leap into action
turning you into an apex predator on the
pitch and in life don't found that
Avenue useful and interesting guys if
you did then please leave a like comment
down below and let me know if I've
missed out anything that you used to
train your neck but lots more like this
on the way and of course we're nearly
now at a hundred thousand subscribers so
thank you so much for that I've got some
really cool stuff coming to celebrate
that I'm going to return to some of the
most popular topics on this channel so
if that sounds cool then hit the
subscribe button and stick around of
course as many of you know I've also
recently released a PDF ebook you can
find information about that in the link
down below and it's selling extremely
well so thank you so much for all the
support there it's been fantastic
includes a full training plan which
incorporates stuff like this into a
training regime to their training more
than just muscle yeah that's about it
thanks a ton for watching guys and I'll
see you next time bye for now
[Music]